on sait qu'on est arrivé à peine hermens
parce qu'on a les tourelles de chez les
tribus les c'est dommage qu'elle fasse
pas qu'elle disparaisse parce qu elle a
toujours fait partie du patrimoine c'est
loin d'être une verrue dans le paysage
tout aurait plutôt valoriser cette
maison
[Musique]
aujourd'hui
dans les calanques de marseille des
outer ont été délivrés aux petits du
patrimoine et des outer sont délivrées
aussi outils du patrimoine sur l'île aux
oiseaux dans le bassin d'arcachon est
donc effectivement on a deux poids deux
mesures c'est à dire que si vous êtes
corse et si vous êtes marseillais les
choses se passent plus facilement pour
vous
[Musique]
monsieur le préfet essaie de trouver la
solution pour que ma mère puisse garder
cette maison jusqu'à sa mort c'est à
dire qu'à sa mort la maison ne serait
pas démoli et les cli retournerai au
préfet